l'oeuvre d'un collectif qui est
d'ailleurs en train de prendre plein
d'énergie là autour de cette racine
géante en vérité ce que vous voyez là et
dieu sait ce que vous ne voyez pas la
plupart du temps c'est ce qui se passe
sous terre et ce jardin c'est une
invitation au voyage voyage souterrain
et c'est julien qui va nous servir de
guide aujourd'hui bonjour julien retour
aux racines du coup ça se passe sous
terre pourquoi sous terre pourquoi vous
êtes vous intéressé au sol le sol est
porteur de beaucoup de surprises depuis
darwin on pense que le vivant se
développe avec la compétition la lutte
de tous contre tous et dans le sous sol
on piétine on marche dessus mais il ya
tout un monde à découvrir notamment
entre les racines et les champignons ya
ce qu'on appelle la symbiose
mycorhizienne et cette symbiose est en
fait une incroyable preuve d' entraide
entre deux de règne les végétaux et les
champignons
l'un apporte avec la photosynthèse le
sucre et les champignons amène minéraux
communication entre système racinaire et
de multiples autres
ou est ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'on
découvre de jour en jour parce que ça
bouscule vraiment ce qu'on avait établi
depuis darwin qui est la compétition et
la lutte
voilà du le plus fort gagne quand on
vous a parlé vous de biomimétisme vous
ai dit ok très bien j'ai pas envie qu'on
parle d'une application concrète de ce
que peut inspirer la nature est ce que
parce qu'elle peut produire
vous vous êtes dit j'ai plus envie qu'on
parle d'une certaine philosophie de vie
oui tout à fait oui c'est plus qu'une
inspiration la nature technique on
pensait plus à une inspiration projet
une et paysagistes architectes
paysagistes du coup le projet le coeur
de notre métier c'est la méthodologie de
projet
le point de départ c'est
la démarche qu'on a face à un site c'est
à dire sa compréhension son histoire son
sol l'entr'aide qui peut se créer entre
les différents acteurs vivants végétaux
animaux
voilà toute cette démarche de
compréhension et d'entrer dans un projet
de paysage est vraiment essentiel est la
première posture à avoir que du coup le
sol l'inspirent et donc le sol
contrairement à peut-être à nous tous
qui n'y faisons presque jamais attention
on marche dessus mais parce qu'on estime
que c'est là et que ça a toujours été là
en fait pour vous c'est une richesse et
quelque chose à défendre un patrimoine
incroyable en fait oui tout à fait le
sol ses marrons ces bourgs eux ces sales
cloud
pas glamour du tout on pourrait même
dire plutôt que terre végétale terre
animal parce que ce sont les vers de
terre par un travail assez besogneux qui
crée ce complexe argilo unique
donc voilà c'est les excréments de des
vers de terre qu'il faut soit super bien
l'avouer c'est moins bien mais c'est ce
sol qui est nourricier et qui va permet
aussi bien la beauté et la poésie d'être
l'homme et nous nourrir au niveau de
l'alimentation de construire de maisons
de là de nos sociétés sont bâtis sur le
sol et ce sol qui est en érosion
perpétuel et en imperméabilisation enfin
est sujet à beaucoup de destruction est
vraiment un point de vigilance assez
important à une base d'engagements à
préserver nos sols c'est vrai que grâce
à bond sera peut-être un petit peu plus
vigilant à ce qui se passe sous nos
pieds